en suivant le petit prince c'est un
atelier d'écriture à la ferme du
mousseau d'elancourt accompagné par
l'écrivain et poète dominique cagnard
les participants rédige sur le thème du
petit prince de saint-exupéry l'écriture
je me tiens même surtout la poésie c'est
pas une course c'est pas marathon alors
à l'atelier d'écriture c'est pas un
marathon c'est prendre son temps
s'arrêter reprendre retrouver son
souffle pour prendre leur temps les
participants débute par une lecture unis
il rédige ensuite un texte autour de
laives le sujet est libre à plusieurs
l'inspiration vient plus facilement le
fait de travailler en groupe ne pas être
seul devant une feuille de d'avoir des
de bénéficier de conseils d'être avec
des gens stimulant d'être de d'avoir des
pistes à suivre pour débloquer
l'écriture pour ne pas faire face au
syndrome de la page blanche tout seul
j'ai tendance à commencer à mouliner fin
c'est le cérébral qui prend le dessus ça
me stresse à ferme je me dis oh bah je
sais pas faire et puis j'arrête
alors que là bas je continue avec les
autres en suivant le petit prince est
accessible dès 12 ans habitué d'écriture
ou simple initié tout le monde petits
participer à un atelier proposé un
partenariat avec la maison de la poésie
proposé aux gens de s'impliquer de
s'investir et de réussir à mettre des
mots peut-être sur des choses sur
lesquelles il n'aura peut-être pas
penser d'écrire un jour les textes
écrits lors de l'atelier seront exposées
à la ferme du mousseau le 22 et 23
février un spectacle autour du petit
prince sera proposé dimanche à 17h30
quant aux ateliers d'écriture ils
reprendront ce samedi autour du thème de
l'univers de la femme